[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARSH GARDINER: While wiring up
your API runtime with proxies
is a big step in
an API's lifecycle,
it marks the beginning
of a larger effort
to drive awareness,
adoption, and usage.
Now let's talk about how
you, an API provider,
can publish this
functionality in order
to attract and engage
the people who develop
the apps that use your API.
These developers
are your consumers.
You can create a great
experience for your consumers
using Apigee's API publishing
tools and developer
portals, whether
your APIs are meant
for internal or
external use or both.
A great developer experience
requires an intuitive catalog
of APIs, detailed documentation
for each of those products,
and an easy onboarding process.
Let's see how those work.
Here's an API.
I can see the request
and response format,
and I can see that this API
uses an API key for security.
That's really valuable.
After seeing the
API documentation,
the next step a developer
will want to take
is to get credentials
that allows their app
to access that API.
The developer portal
provides that too.
A consumer can just
register and sign
in using their credentials,
or you, the provider,
can delegate that
authentication step
to your company's single sign-on
service, or SSO, using SAML.
Once I've signed in, I can
see my client applications
listed for me, though, at
first, I don't have any,
so let's create one.
Clicking through, I can
then manage the products
authorized for that app.
Now I can see my new API
key, so fast and easy.
Now let's try the interactive
documentation again.
Paste in my API key, and
it works, all right here
within the developer portal.
This really helps developers
get started rapidly.
And of course, there are tools
that an API publisher can
use to easily customize the
portal to match their brand
guidelines.
Clicking through,
this page gives access
to the theme and styling, the
portal pages, various settings
and assets like
images and so on.
And here, I can add my API
products to the catalog.
A developer portal is a
key part of an API program,
and this is just a
taste of how it works.
An Apigee developer portal
helps your developers discover,
explore, test, and learn so they
can build on top of your APIs
quickly and securely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]